[Music]
my
archives are at the northern tip of the
desolate sands
there we will find my body and
the black soapstone liar
we both know you will betray us the
first chance you get
i am many things templar but i
am
for
your example there is nothing you have
to say that would interest
me
meet your destiny
here is the entrance to my archives
let me act
i had to build all of this for my
research
and my experiments
the black soul stones complicated
creation
i sacrificed much to make
beyond these portals lie two relics that
were once powered by my blood
take the vials you recovered and use
them to activate the relics
i will stay here and prepare the ritual
be careful
angels are no better than demons
did you know that they once voted on
whether or not to eliminate
all of mankind only one fate
saved us from extinction
there is no justice in murder
these fallen lunatics are the most
unstable of their kind
causing them to over produce highly
combustible fluids in their abdomens
i believe this imbalance must be
impossible
their stomachs and release their
explosive vial in a
terrible display when enemies
this cannot be opened yet
not enough fury
no way
more fury
your flesh impossible
a glorious development
the enchantress is quite intriguing
wouldn't you agree does she really
captivate you so
hey
ah
i could have helped all men become
nephilim
and ushered in a golden age but my
herodrick brothers
could not accept man's true destiny
need more time
no way
i have unlocked the secret of the soul
stones once given to the horadram
by tyriel an impressive creation
to be we will feel the shadow locks with
vials of his blood
and we will hide the blood in the desert
under eternal
god i can only hope that the world does
not forget
of course even after everything we've
come to know about sultan maybe adria is
right
ah
[Music]
i need fury
already
i can't
more fury no way
that was the worthy folk glorious
[Music]
uh
so
i need fury
you cannot stand before me
we all agree that the end times are upon
us
but do you truly believe that belial and
asmodan
this must be the shadow portal let us be
done with this
did all this to lock my body away
they must have been very angry with me
they knew your plans you had to be
stopped
[Music]
they were never very imaginative
not enough beauty
more fury
impossible
[Applause]
you winked against my flows
still recharged
[Applause]
ancient smile on me
i need fury
always wanted to fight some of these
[Applause]
i try to shut him out but his chattering
is teethless
it enjoys daunting me i will not rise to
the bait
i will not give in to him i long for the
silence that will come once i secure his
head away
but seek its mastery only its salvation
oh my god
i need more time
i have cool's body then let me begin the
ritual
but i'm
you are surrounded by deceit young one
i am the least of your concerns
concentrate leah soon now
just a bit longer just
a moment almost yes
my blood thunders within me
this wetted air fills my ravaged
lungs i
am alive again
you're welcome you got what you wanted
now give us the soul stone very well
the bargain stands quickly
to my sanctum
what is this
how has this happened the souls of the
dead lords of hell have been absorbed
into the stone
abandon your quest nephilim
your allies seek only to control you
with the power i offer you and i
could rule over all creation
you're mad cool give me the stone but i
will destroy
no way
not ready
need more time
uh
it seems my brothers have finally come
looking for me
five lords of hell now reside within
this stone
this was your doing adrian twenty years
ago
during the darkening of tristram kane
told me of zoltan cool's profane
soul stone
so that they could be drawn into cool's
vessel yes my daughter
i have sacrificed everything for this
i need to go back
what will we do when we've trapped
belial and asthma then i will shatter
smiles on me